all right this is episode 7 yes because
the last one yeah yeah um please count
yes and this is we get to see who
trained their double which I mean I get
knowing nothing about the comics and you
know just going off the movie I even
though someone did train them it makes
so much more sense but well but then
again the chemicals enhance a lot now
the other thing I don't remember a stick
being in the Aflac film no that's what
I'm saying like a train didn't sob so I
think it was personally better seen a
stick you know well okay here's the
question can you see in a head do they
ever address that the chemicals actually
I mean I know blind people can then
their other sentence are heightened but
do they actually address that the
chemicals do heighten everything else
for these two because it seems like even
for a blind person this seems like
really advanced no I don't know some of
this stuff comes under the later
incarnation the Miller one stick belongs
to a group called the chaste and there's
like there's like a few of them and
they've all got names like my favorite
is shaft oh really yeah there's a stick
and the other one I remember is there is
stone because I was like oh sticks and
stones I don't think he was chemically
enhanced I think he's just he's like
kind of he's super ninja they go up
against there's like a group of ninjas
and they're already hinting at in this
called the hand and so it's the chaste
kind of version so you know the hand
okay yeah they're there I mean that's
there's sort of a connection already
with the Yakuza and so there's this
other fight going on so yeah I I don't
remember stick I don't think that was
chemical he was born blind hmm
and I think just through his martial
arts training and you know Marvel magic
or whatever hey you know like but I know
I don't ever remember being exposed to
chemicals what little I remember maybe
I'm wrong someone can correct well I'm
not now putting together yeah I kind of
do this I'm just now making the
conviction that this stick is the same
stick that splinter satirizing in the
Turtles
he's very good and stuff like that you
know and I know the foot is the hand as
well but I knew that hand was even
before ya know before I do that same
time oh they addressed him a few times
in x-men the hand I know it's like just
a big ninja gang pretty much yeah so if
you have a vague recollection of that
that's where we're going well and I love
um you know origin stories where a
master is training the apprentice and
stuff can either be done so well or so
recycled and so boring and I think this
is done really well right cuz sticks
just such a dick
yeah but you also see Larry you see
where he's for the most part where he's
coming from you sir see how it works and
and in his philosophy and then I like
even attached
it's very Game of Thrones do I get a 10
but I like how they go as well into what
does that you know what's the drawing
point you know what the point we go too
far I mean if this black sky kid thing
whatever I guess a like Scott Glenn says
it but up ku sky blue sky Kuzco like
yeah I have no idea what that thing is I
mean like my first thought is maybe like
so glad you asked I have no fucking clue
not a clue I never thought was maybe
like was again I only mostly know x-men
so I know there's a guy either cold like
the shadow king or the shadow master so
I thought maybe something like that
there's there's like three options we
can go with alien connecting it somehow
to you know
the Infinity Gauntlet and then the whole
invasion from Avengers mutant connecting
it someone like x-men or demon well
whichever it is Scott blend pretty much
served sticks just like it's something
you don't want in your world there's how
he said so it's I'm taking it that he's
not fully human yeah but who the hell
yeah I have no I have no clue if it's a
comic reference is beyond me either
I don't I mean it looks like are we
doing apocalypse and um you know the
next x-men and IV but they hit they had
a pretty young in the shot that they
showed but there's but I don't think
that's a connection there's a couple
connections I can talk about later cuz I
don't want to give things away with
other characters but there is another
loser connection maybe to another series
involving martial arts and supernatural
cities they but I don't like how do I
get into the eggs I don't give anything
away but even then that's I'm just
guessing on that and I don't know that
series as well either so the the show
does really well it's sort of like I
guess Marvel always has done this well
since they started the Pacific
University of poking like you know and
my be this or did you know that these
little Easter eggs but still keeping you
engaged in the story they're not like
you know yeah well is this a it's just
subtle enough where it's like you know
like the the black base of spades you
know for yeah balls how you did it and I
fly else what they quit that yeah and
maybe there's I think the guy at the end
of this one is supposed to be stick had
a second-in-command then that was stone
I think that's supposed to be stone he's
talking to I think but it's one of them
it's definitely one of the group of the
chase like that much is certain
oh but yeah so I like a little hints to
do without getting to I it's not like
Laura the rig's like you know or the new
Hobbit it's like it Legolas I want you
to meet this range of thought who is he
Aragorn
hmm okay
eight that shinbei when they do it so
terrible but these are such nice little
touches that even if you don't know it
wouldn't be too distracting it's still
sort of it pulls you in um but what
about Senor foggy I just love hearing
the words Senor foggy does your neighbor
what I mean come to someone actually
called foggy year I mean it's after
Wyoming okay what's his real fucking
name why did I use everyone gonna come
fucking foggy um no you know love for
the fog man I I will say this there's
something about like okay if this chick
like she's got her mace and stuff and
she's not especially strong and so so if
he comes in and saves her it's like okay
fair enough but it's like when she's
sprays the guys like I could take care
of myself
don't do that shit man don't do it hello
she's strong because when somebody saves
her if she says hey I don't need to be
say it doesn't work that way yeah here's
here's how it works if you kick this ass
first and then foggy I'm gonna walk in
yeah but when basically you have some
guy throw a baseball at another guy and
hit him with a bat and you've done
nothing so far and then spray him once
he's bad take care of myself no other
offensive remaining for you know is what
you say you just got saved by foggy yeah
you know saying I can take care of
myself back to base it doesn't make you
like a strong you know like strong will
whatever no it makes you a bitch I will
say this I did yeah but that's that's
what's going on there is she suddenly
Phelps and suddenly realized just like I
look like a schmuck
so she's just angry just like I'd take
care of myself like you know it's like
anytime somebody gets caught screwing up
and they're like what what I got this
even though they just completely fucked
up like that's what's going on they're
like idiot if that was the case they
didn't explain that joke Oh see I got it
right away I think she was just like hey
I'm not even sure she believed it in
that moment like the Joker sort of like
he says she's thanking him later when
they're talking to Urich and she's again
Fogg he just kicks ass like so there
she's admitted that I think
the heat at the moment though is like
what what I don't know buddy help the
joke would work if she's like I could
take care of myself and then like the
guy's about to stab her and then he like
hits him again with a baseball bat or
something like that that would be
completing a joke but her spraying hey I
can take care of my tits like I don't
know what they were going for exactly I
did like a sign after day can we not
discuss this in front of the but but
yeah a night everyone's gonna be like oh
so you think she's a bitch
no she's a fine characters nothing wrong
with her is the one for the anger tumblr
dudes just like what was that about my
personal opinion is like anybody who
gets caught screwing up she's in denial
mode in the split second like what I'm
fine everything's fine how are you like
you know I think that's what was going
on there man baby I did a good thing
that's how that's how I read it but but
no I really like these stories about
like you know that the sensei and the
you know the one being trained if
they're done well and miss frozen enough
twists and turns they make it just
interesting and badass enough and again
I'm always fascinated when I can watch
these two just in a bench and I feel
like they're sitting there for a long
time but I'm so interested so what
there's young scene and it really worked
I speed off of every word no it was as
the kid I'm glad he's given more to do
and does not think he did this against
the rain he did but he's given much more
opportunity to shine in this how many
really good how many crappy kid actors
have we seen just reviewing and like
doing in nostalgia critics and like this
kid is legitimately really good well the
next one we gotta do cause it does start
kids but see how that and I will say
like remembering how stick looked back
in the day the way it was drawn Scott
Glenn perfect cast
I'm he's like I want the hair a little
Messier but apart from the hair I'm like
I'm just like yeah
yeah I'm like that stick that's exactly
I'm like good good casting on that what
the hell else happened
I mean the I mean really it's all on
them I mean for the monarch because he
is such a good interesting never give
your son say ice cream wrappers to
represent friendship he may hold on to
it but he just won't be your sensei
anymore
so yeah the kind of statics see here's
the here's the funny thing I know it
kind of upset you I find that even more
dickish because that does that just
means he's like you know I'd deep down
they really do care for this kid but
fucking he can complete his own goddamn
I can't show that I'm like huh no no
that's exactly what I do get that he
does care but he's he's not the one he
was looking for for this you know
because they cannot care for each other
but he just completely a bit like
abandons him all the guy it's a dig Hedy
not a handy just completely tossed it
and we never saw it again
like I would have found that less
dickish I find it more dickish you
actually Betty kind of held out I don't
know because that just means like wow
he's so calm compartmentalized is like
life that he's just like well I guess
technically I still care well hold on
drip Oh make him think well well I think
they're trying to show to that it's like
he's you know he believes his philosophy
but he's flawed as well cuz even he
didn't drop that on purpose I'm positive
that was an accident
yeah which means Murdoch never would
have even known like yeah but it's uh I
know I love it yeah I like because it's
just show he is flawed you know then I
truly believe he believes his philosophy
but he you know he can be flawed too he
can hold on to this thing you know and
keep it for all these years wow this is
that like he has to believe it like he's
got this group of the chased and he's
fighting the hand and now we've got all
the other shit going on in the Marvel
comic universe like you know and
Avengers and stuff like this so it is
funny because this show with its hints
really kind of drops how what a
dangerous time this is and this universe
seems like anything that can and will go
wrong it's just gonna happen yeah I
don't know why you know this darkness
and this heavy stuff being thrown in
because I would usually have a problem
with this like you know come on I even
sort of brought up before you know this
Avengers world with Iron Man and Captain
America instead which can have happy
moments but this is really fucking dark
heavy stuff and brutal and I'm not sure
why it works here it could just be the
characters are so well done in that then
it's got the right focus in the right
place and it sucks you in just at the
right pace in the right and the right
amount and it introduces new characters
at just the right time that I'm I buy it
enough um I think I think it's a number
of things there's that it's really well
done it introduces new characters unlike
the other superheroes it's told from the
ground up and it's told from bottom up
instead of top down like outside of
spider-man and some of the other ones
like a lot of it is like Iron Man I'm
super rich Thor I'm a god you know
Captain America is made to be a super
genetic warrior you know a lot of them
seem like high and lofty compared to you
know I'm so dude in a black mask just
running around kicking criminal scum
like it's very low-key even more low-key
even Batman early on um and then on top
of that I think just we I think the
Marvel Universe in the state it's in
right now with the movies and everything
kind of needs this yeah like I feel like
we need something dark to say no this
means something real people are getting
hurt is that just Avengers where we're
gonna crack wise and do something like
that like this affects people yeah and
we love endures as yeah yeah I love I
love The Avengers and I you know I love
Iron Man and a lot of the Marvel movies
but it is a 1 it is a one-trick pony
after a while I can't for a while it's
like you know I think we need to Ratchet
it up a little and like you know make
this important like as much as I like
something like guardians of the galaxy
like I I need a little dark and gritty
just to remind this is fucking up real
people's lives is a little more
universe and as great as these
characters are in Avengers and I love
watching them in their individual movies
and stuff and they are such fun
characters uh even more yeah kind of a
variety of going into the really we can
have the really light and fluffy like
our into the galaxy we can get the
really dark and gritty like with their
does the same reason I enjoy the flash
like it's the opposite with DC it's like
that's normally their territory and it's
like penguins I need some kind of just
old-school fun goofy out of these people
like admits when that's why it works
both of those shows yeah they're outside
of the normal box that they're normally
doing so it's a good contrast I think
they work really well and you know I'll
admit watching uh watching this and
again you see his origin story now in
the middle so you know what's building
up to uh it really reminds me a lot of a
Batman Begins how he took a story that
you know I say I've seen this a million
times I'm not sure I want to see it
again especially with Batman I was very
kind of closed off to the idea of like
showing his backstory but it's done so
well and I love it when something can
surprise me when I'm going in thinking I
don't want to see this I don't want to
know this stuff and then I'd say well
I'm really glad I know that now like
it's actually a really fascinating point
if you watch just like daredevil Batman
Begins was a surprise like both of these
were big surprises cuz I thought the
same thing I'm like I don't know this is
gonna work like we had the Affleck film
isn't that and we're doing a TV show and
daredevil and like I went in the Batman
Begins singing the same thing and I came
out a movie like wow that was really
really good
yeah and uh or juiced up especially in
that movie yeah and I'm very nicely done
I wouldn't have expected that you know
cuz the last one we had was bad mini
Robin and you know the last thing we had
in this universe via this was the Ben
Affleck they're both so not their finest
hours but yeah I totally agree it
reminds me a lot of Batman Begins yeah
and and it's just it's well done and
again that writing as much as Batman
Begins can you know over talk a little
bit um they still can't they turn the
training at least they can what was
saying you know just like you know
here's the important meaty stuff here's
the meeting none of you Batman Begins is
one of the least
Nolan II films for some of the Nolan
tropes of like the good chug it still
got you know like I don't compare it in
snowy mountains it's fucking the who
cares about fucking snowy mountains I'm
talking about the overwritten lines of
dialogue and philosophy then drones on
and I'm like and I love the dark night
but I mean if you put famine begins Dark
Knight and Dark Knight Rises together
Dark Knight and Dark Knight Rises I
remember amore in my head as being
series of speeches where as famine
begins I feel like there was nothing
more story but you notice begins has the
speeches or lay it has a lot of a but
it's at a time where you need those
speeches they're much the development
he's coming together he's figuring stuff
out and he's stating it you know through
these big developments then we becomes
Batman there's much less of those
speeches they're still they're a couple
but there's much less in Dark Knight as
much as I love the Dark Knight now again
there's a lot yeah give him when he's
Batman there's still these speeches like
you know and some of them yeah are very
good but like I think of that as one of
the big Nolan isms and I felt like
Batman Begins that less so good you know
what because because I think the
conversation with that kid like we said
they're sitting there and they're just
talking and for what it's not speeches
they are talking evil wait.you says do
not have tasks yeah yo aces do not ask I
mean which is something no one can't do
the save his life is right natural
dialogue all of his dialogue sounds
rehearsed like you're watching a play
it's almost like Shakespeare like it's
very you know and which for
Shakespearean moments are fine there are
many Shakespearean moments in Batman but
you know it's but yeah that's something
Nolan can't do like this right natural
dialogue but you know hear the dialogue
felt natural in what is some of it's
still goofy like yeah I mean it still
it's a good blend of like hey there's
talking like teacher and students I mean
it's very clearly what's going on when
you're talking like teacher and student
so he says you know you know you don't
ask anything and then he'll talk again
but he's teaching you know so when
you're teaching you can get away with
that and when the kid again they take
very select dialogue for the kid to say
and it's very good and he's impressed
weights like that's not answering the
questions like you
fast it's like that it's good dialogue
for them to say and put them to work off
of each other it's an actual
conversation even though he's teaching
him and he tells him not to talk but
when he does it's a conversation it's
learning and it's teaching I think the
other the other little thing that I
liked about this and it's something most
people don't care about or notice but
Scott Glenn's really speaking Japanese I
don't mean that they would just make up
fake Japanese but to the point that he
pronounces black sky but I could Scott
like he makes it sound Japanese I
actually thought I watch enough damn
anime yeah I watch enough anime that I'm
just like no he's really trying his
damndest like he's totally throwing on
the Engrish here it's not black sky its
butt up Cruz sky I like it I'm like this
I would almost swear like I'm watching
an anime you know it's not perfect but
I'm like the the attention to detail to
do a little something like that instead
of just saying black sky out of nowhere
this geez much better than much Brandon
Kristen's Spanish which you can just
hear I I don't speak Spanish but you can
hear the American accent her character
wouldn't need to know Spanish Flu me she
said in the beginning veggies like I see
anyway and she's guys struggling out
where his god Glenn's character is
supposed to be immersed in this world
fighting this current Japanese ninja
clan like it's just those little details
I love those um it just shows the extra
attention you know an effort thrown into
this and a great start to I think when
you see the guy running down he goes
into the place if he gets a gun to close
it the points a deal up here and stuff I
just applaud immediately not invested
yeah what a great opening I got just oh
what the other attention to detail is
when the guy gets his hand locked off
into Twitter so yeah that's witching
timing or what a great addition love it
see this is what we did the honest
thoughts earlier and we're talking about
lack of gore in things like this is what
I'm
we're sick but but you know you know you
know what it is I think because we do
get so desensitized to violence because
it is everywhere and stuff that when you
see a hand cut off it's like it means
nothing we see the million times but
then we'd see that twitch it adds a
little Moo I mean you get a little twit
twoo watching they're just like well
yeah they went that extra mile and if
both makes it a little bit more badass
but a little bit more like uncomfortable
- it resonates because you're like okay
this is even for a comedy show this is
like real yeah like it I know versus
desensitized sort of violence we're just
like Oh some kind gets his hand cut off
and you barely see the hand and the guy
like just like that but like this guy
I'm like I really believe got his hand
cut out tonight yeah it's they still
address that this is uncomfortable yeah
you know it's not quite it's not quite
fortuitous for the sake of like you know
something like the cell or something
like that where it's just so in your be
Steve do you know it's very much like
we're still coming up does it mean yeah
we're we're still comic book but we're
going to be a pretty fucking adult comic
book and you got to be prepared we're
gonna treat this you know pretty intense
but not exploitative you know it doesn't
feel exploitive to me you know it's just
a right value it's a good balance for
what this is um so yeah that's been it
we will see you the next one late